SHOTS.
MAKING SURE YOU DO THE RIGHT
THING -- THEY'VE GOT TO BE
WE SAW A LOT OF HIM LASTSK PLAY,
MANAGE THE GAME.SK
JACOB ELVIS PLAYING HIS HIS
DYLAN STROME8 MINUTES.
HOW ABOUT ZACH WERENSKI?
HE GETS ON HIS PORCH AND BACK TO
BREAK THAT
AN EXCELLENT
POKED OFF TO THE CORNER.
INCOMING. RESULT.OCKED ACROSS T.
THEY ARE TO CLEAN IT UP.
RIGHT A LIKABLE GUY.
HIS TEAMMATES
EARLY.
BOUNCING ZACH WERENSKI ALSO PIC.
POKED OFF OF HIS STICK.
RIGHT THE NET.
THOSE ARE THE COSTS THE
GOAL LINE.
5-ON-5.Y
>> 24 SECONDS.
MURPHY MURPHY GET THAT IN
LONG SHOT.
SENT WIDE TO
JUST SLIDES BY THE NET.
ICING, THE
PEEKE WAS DROPPED IN FRONT
MINOR PENALTY, HOOKING. THE WAL.
JENNER CUTS IT OFF.
IT CHIPPED O O
CROSS ICE!
FLEURY TOOK
CENTER.
RICK ROBINSON.
NYQUIST.
SPUN AROUND BYRON PASS OUT. PAS.
STROME ACROSS THE LINE.
LELEREE BIG GUYS
OUT THERE. PERIOD.
WHAT A BEAT THERE,
HE HAS GOT
WERENSKI WITH HIM THE WHOLE WAY,
BUBU
THE JACKETS
>> YORKSTRAND TRIED TO SLIDE NEA